in the wake of the finding by a New York
jury that Donald Trump is liable for
sexual assault and defamation against
writer E Gene Carroll in that Bergdorf
Goodman Department Store in New York
City in the 1990s we now have a Cascade
of Serial sexual harassment allegations
against Donald Trump
from a former staffer while he was
President of the United States there was
maybe the belief I don't know I mean you
know sometimes it's like these serial
harassers and assaulters
they don't often stop particularly not
when they're in positions of power but
there were dozens of allegations of
different levels of sexual assault
against Trump from sort of like verbal
harassment all the way up to rape
dozens of them
in periods of time before Donald Trump
became president of the United States a
former staffer is now accusing Trump of
sexual harassment in the White House
Newsweek reports staffers who worked in
Trump's White House have accused him of
sexual harassment
the uh okay so a lot of this news is
about the verdict which we've already
talked about and Trump's reaction
discussing the verdict on CNN Alyssa
Farah Griffin who quit as Trump's White
House comes director in December of 2020
said Trump had a pattern of Behaving
inappropriately with women while in the
white house she noted she wasn't the
only one to report such Behavior to
Trump's Chief of Staff take a look at
this clip from CNN stunning but not
altogether surprising listen when Donald
Trump tells you who he is believe him um
I mean that is this is it we wanted to
chalk it up to locker room talk in 2016.
it was not locker room talk now he is
credibly he has been he's now been
charged with or I should say held liable
in this case for actually committing
sexual assault like I cannot underscore
that enough that your guest before made
an incredibly important Point any man or
woman who was falsely accused would be
the first person to show up and to
defend themselves in a rape allegation
or a sexual assault allegation he
couldn't be bothered to show up I have
countless cases of what I considered
impropriety in the white house that I
brought to the chief of staff because I
thought the way he engaged with women
was dangerous this is I mean we know
these facts the patterns have laid out
and now this is something that's not
just speculation it's not just
allegations it is a jury of his peers
deciding that he did this wait you
brought to Mark Meadows the chief of
staff or other Chiefs of Staff incidents
that you witnessed of Donald Trump
behaving in inappropriately with women I
did as well as a former White House
Press Secretary Stephanie Grisham and
others nothing that rises to this level
but things that I would consider
improper and that I had a duty to report
and this is all out there voters need to
pay attention and folks in my own party
need to stop making apologies for this
man is there anything more you can tell
us about this
I
if I'm able to I will share more all
right you have to come on this show to
tell it though those are major major
allegations now I want to zoom out a
little bit
the broader story with these major
allegations against Trump follows this
pattern
we hear one allegation
and Maga rallies around Trump and most
Republicans do and say it's made up
and then we get more allegations that
now start to become a pattern and it
becomes much more difficult to say that
it's made up I'll give you an example
Cassidy Hutchinson testified to the
January 6th committee when Democrats
still controlled the house before
January of this year Cassidy Hutchinson
testified
Trump lunged at a secret service agent
and demanded that he be brought I don't
even remember where it was where his the
rioters were whatever
and the reaction was that's so out of
character for Trump trump would never do
that Trump doesn't have a temper no it's
all it's all very clearly made up and
then a couple of weeks ago we get yet
another story
recent one which we have on a recording
which is Trump lunged at a reporter on
his plane because the reporter was
asking Trump what questions that Trump
did not want to answer and Trump
snatched the guy's phone out of his hand
and tossed it oh so it's the exact same
pattern of lunging at people when they
are talking to you about something you
don't want to talk about or telling you
something that you don't want to hear
it starts to become more and more
difficult to deny these things
particularly when they're recorded so
now we have another version of this
Trump sexually harassed one two 25 30 40
women before Trump became president it's
all fake it's totally out of character
okay we now have a court finding a jury
has found Trump is liable for sexual
assault and then defaming the woman who
accused him of the sexual assault he
owes her five million dollars oh well
that's also BS and now a former staffer
says oh by the way the exact same
pattern that e Gene Carroll alleged from
the 1990s dozens of other women alleged
during the 2000s it didn't stop when
Trump was in the white house it's all
the same story and so the right the Maga
right some Republicans who continue to
defend this this guy will insist these
are just these allegations are so hard
to believe they're just so Random
they're being made up they're being
weaponized these allegations of Trump's
temper Trump's snapping at people
lunging at people sexually harassing
sexually assaulting and going beyond
that with women
it's a decades-long pattern it's a
decades-long pattern that goes back
one of Trump's former wives I now forget
which one I think it was Ivana said
Trump sexually assaulted her multiple
times how can it all be this concerted
effort to defame Trump when first a jury
quite literally found that it was
actually Trump who did the defamation
and it's the same stories from women who
don't even know each other who have
nothing to do Alyssa Farah Griffin and
what she observed when she worked for
Trump
a few years ago has nothing to do with
what happened to Eugene Carroll or what
Trump's ex-wife alleged or what you know
the young women from the Miss whatever
pageant where Trump would go backstage
it's all unrelated individuals who don't
know each other and the pattern that's
emerging is these stories seem to be
corroborated again and again and again
from unrelated sources that's really the
Revelation here so tonight there's a
town hall on CNN
is it going to be handled responsibly is
it going to be handled the way it should
be handled given the insanity of who
Trump is and has become I'm not
confident but we're going to talk about
that after the break make sure make sure
you subscribe to the YouTube channel
youtube.com the davidpackman show make
sure you're following us on Tick Tock
for the short form content and make sure
you've signed up at joinpakman.com